who called it baby this guy let's cry
for help which you clearly have all the
attention you need no he he called that
pearl what's gonna be the one that was
ahh yeah you know but again like a good
like good writing works even if you see
it coming it's still done so well and it
opens up so many great opportunities and
great discussions it was the second time
she fused I'm like she's enjoying this
way too much I'm like she yeah why what
I love is I even when it showed her
crying at the beginning like don't cry
pearl like they made it funny so you
wouldn't immediately suspect like you
know she would want to do it cuz she
obviously really liked it but it could
be a goofy moment it could be a silly
moment um katia more messed up this show
really is so good um they always know
just the right balance of detail and
vagueness and they know exactly how much
to give
so that hey we're not talking about
nothing we're talking about something
that you can connect with but it's still
like just vague enough that you can
connect it to so many various some
random scenes I was like early on I was
just like I would have killed to be a
layout artist on this show the
background work some of the production
design even storyboarding it just I just
love all of the layout work it's I can't
quite pin it down there's some of it
some of the faded colors and stuff it
reminds me of the 70s some of it is very
1960s and some of it in the color scheme
is 80 it's it's this very sort of pan 60
70s 80s sort of work where they took
sort of the best of everything it it
really is its own little universe I'm
like I can't pinpoint exactly what it's
doing but even when they fused I mean
that was I said that was Mario world
what they play it was almost like the
Mario world star music today you know uh
you know it's like that I do I will say
garnet and pearls fusion that's not what
I expected it was gonna be no and
honestly like it's just like well it
definitely was not
as cool as garnet and amethyst yeah
that's still my favorite when they fuse
to get evil for a second oh my god
interesting this one is interesting goes
on I'm like well I can definitely sense
pearl win this yeah it's not something
where I'm like oh what a disappointment
it's not like that there was like Magnus
to it I actually like but it was yeah it
was very fastidious and like uh sort of
a almost like a fancy lounge singer egg
like there's kind of a class to it in a
little bit of comedy and yeah which I
wouldn't expect kind of got about words
a little fast I'm not gonna read it I
think maybe that was the point but but
again I kind of liked that I I didn't
see it coming and it sort of forces me
to think well why would it kind of be
like that you know that my first rash
was wow that's not what I expected yeah
like I like you know sin yet to be like
you know is it just the excitement of
the character is it just the enthusiasm
you know uh you know sort of taking over
or sort of sharing because they both
seem very hey you know even garnet was
very happy afterwards they're like you
know jumping up and down like you know
they loved it everything afterwards not
so much no um and I again it shows I
think this one's good cuz it also shows
the seriousness of fusion again not
totally understanding the culture but
you know like this is something that you
kind of do it's it's a major thing it's
a major part in like you know a
relationship or like a connect it's a
major connection uh you know and and
like friendship you can get a high
office music that was like a dry tie but
know what like it can be like friendship
it can be like a romantic relationship
it can be like sex it can be like you
know kissing it can be like any of them
when you see that in like I tend to see
the next averts more but I've seen
introverts I definitely get it where you
get this like attachment syndrome to a
friend and it's almost like it gets a
little weird I was gonna say I almost
see it in introverts uh more you know
because there is kind of this well
there's like write that one or two Pete
I've seen it in both yeah I mean it
definitely happens to both it's a little
more flighty with extroverts cuz they
can do it with almost anybody but then
jerks when they find the one it's like
yeah
and then one or two people that they're
just going to you know cling to um but
yeah I definitely see the next river
it's it's spread a little more evenly
maybe yeah I think that's it more
they're like they lose that drug high
when they're not around people
whereas with introverts it's like they
can go longer I think without the drug
high but when they get that drug high
they cling to it a little more ya know I
think it's very good way of putting it
um but yeah and I just love you can make
so many connections with that and these
episodes like this I think like anything
with the fusion especially I think I'm
like when Steven and Connie fused it
almost feels like you know like
something out wild strawberries or you
know some sort of a strike film or a
dream or something like that like you
get it like the ideas are there and the
emotions are there just the exact
reasons and logic and details aren't but
they drop just enough so that you can
make that connection to whatever you
want and you still feel it even though
you can't fully explain it and I love
anything that can do it I'm always so
amazed that a children's show can do
that
um so consistently and it's not by
accident and it's so meticulously
planned uh so I again I just I love the
way they do it and it's the dynamic
between the three of it will the for
them really yeah
but Steve like she says it's like we
need to be careful this time so I need
to use pearl you know we're too reckless
when it's the two of us together and
I've I've been in friends groups like
that where if you get a couple of them
together they'll do something crazy
while the other one will be careful if
they're together it it's just like the
the dynamics of friends group and
cliques like I thought that was an
interesting well and how healthy what
how clever to show you from amethyst
point of view of her feeling left out
and that's her that's needed to complete
this job at the end you know because it
only seems to be garnet and amethyst so
I I get that amethyst would feel kind of
like left out and just like buh buh buh
you me garnet and pearl I mean no I said
it only seems to be guarded and amethyst
to me gone Emperor Stoker I know I mean
when they're fusing its garnet and
amethyst
why is it usually old I they do once
Asgard amethyst and then they did once
as the three of them because that's what
they would wanted to do they want to do
all three and they said no that's you
know to crea we can't hurt what was it -
I guess it depends on the dynamic I
always feel like garnet and amethyst
sometimes are closer because they're
more punch first ask questions later
like I mean garnets definitely the more
balanced between garnet and amethyst
she's like a perfect mix between
amethyst and pearl sort of the you know
thinking sit down let's think of a plan
and then the punch first ask questions
never kind of thing to a degree but I
would still group her probably closer to
amethyst and I would pearl and maybe um
but it's one of those things where when
we got to the ending and they just
walked past each other and it's like you
know sometimes life doesn't end like it
doesn't cartoons I'm thinking myself end
stop here stop here and it stops there
and nothing gives me more thrill than
when something stops when I am NOT here
see ya it's like and I love it when it's
again it's like Rocky it just knew the
exact moment to stop when it was just
such a way of saying yeah this isn't
gonna be one of those cartoons I
just like I like just like was like yes
oh my god
these gave a metal finger to all
cartoons that wrap up like so perfectly
at the end of each episode I'm like nope
ya know this um I love it I just love
the new things the new adult things that
they're finding ways to get into kids
shows not only to give kids like you
know a more adult experience but they
can watch it again years later watch it
now I think it really helps develop them
and you know be like hey remember that
really simple show we saw when we were
younger and we like I'm watching again
it actually has a lot more complex ideas
than ever thought of and that forces you
to see the complex and the simple and
the simple in the complex and I love
that love that this show consistent I
always say I could write a book about
pearl and just another page in the book
doesn't be longer than the Bible
just she has so many issues but it's why
I like her the best she's the most
complex character Li's in my opinion but
no she prize the most yeah well like I'm
not saying everything she does is right
there like there's no I said he is she
is in the wrong but it's just like I'm
so fast cause I'm like well I see where
she's coming from like she is so
damaged um even more so than like it
like I get that kind of from amethyst
but I feel amethyst is more of like a
little kid damage like she could still
work through a pearl just as like BIA
she just she's got so much baggage like
she should be sitting at the baggage
claim for hours yeah you know and garnet
it's tender you're gonna be able to fit
all that baggage on that plane honey
garnet is technically two people well
you know doesn't that make sense the
more thing about you know there might be
white garnets more balanced yeah because
it's literally I mean when we saw those
two characters it did seem like hey this
one seems very amethyst this one seems
very pearl you know it oncee much more
logical and thinking and subdued the
others seem much more you know bad
answer braids but is the interesting
thing about pearl is she is so practical
and so think first and you know think
first punch later and making sure it's
right oh I can't see if I was making
sure the volume was going sorry I had on
exposure sorry I didn't see the bar
going but it should still be you know
sorry could I interrupted your take me
out for a cup of coffee first we don't
have to go that fast like straight into
it you don't like white put my head like
that I you know I think we would my
shoulders still smells like you and it's
weirding me out people already work in a
fan art of our fusion our creepy white
creepy fusion why did you have to say
that yeah you know like but by the time
this video ends I want five different
fan arts of art which I was fine with
our twincest pictures we kept getting
but the futures just too far I my face
and your mug or ugly enough as it is we
don't need to combine the two um yeah
sorry finish your thought I really I
didn't remember what my thought was cuz
all I'm thinking of is our fusion and am
I so good in this oh no so it I liked
this episode too because she is so
practical and and thinking
use logic in this and that but
completely throws it out the
window here like complete like her
emotions like that she keeps burying
like is completely interfering with her
work because that logical side just went
out the door well and we see
this like I'm just gonna keep rebuilding
this cuz that's an actual signal
she's putting the planet in danger now
because she's so lonely so I was
like that's why I like this characters
layers and layers and layers and layers
well and we've seen that before in lots
of you people that need a lot of control
and you know need it so much that when
something finally falls apart you know
they'll go to these terrible lengths or
you know even just but they'll sacrifice
emotions so much for control that when
they do actually have saying it's very
emotionally fulfilling they will do
everything they can to control it and
get it over and over and over
um so no I thought this was so well put
I like how really really more damaged
and garnet probably seems like the most
put together and amethyst and she
literally yes what chapter amethyst
damage seems more kind of childlike and
she seems a little more extroverted well
pearl is like the older more introverted
sort of baggage like it says it's really
all three of them put together it just I
love it yeah and there's no there's no
character either I'm realizing more and
more that I'm like oh it's a pearl
episode oh it's an amethyst episode
insta at first I kind of was at first
when it was a my finger on it but it's
like Elphaba that first one it was
amethyst only I was coming like but now
amethyst is really gross like all three
of them like I was more of a garnet
pearl kind of but what makes even better
is that the characters I know the girl
guys this is just you're a pearl girl
um yes okay I gotta make it to you later
Sheriff yeah I may go make it before
this show ends I might have a shirt that
says pearl girl oh you like the
Mabel sweater but with all the
characters you know you go back from the
beginning of watch it nothing has
changed we just found out more about him
and again that is such good writing
that's not like oh this character got
more interesting so they were always the
same we're just finding that's know
right
there's no writers desperation no like
these characters were fleshed out it's I
don't feel like like there's a number of
shows we can feel that the writers
making it up as it goes out stay works I
like talking the Lord of the Rings is it
the tail grew in the telling that was
his way of saying I was making this
up as I guess it doesn't always work and
when it does it works great this one I
feel like these characters like Rebecca
sugar or the writers or whoever there
was some idea in their head from the
beginning I feel like this it wasn't
getting as made up as it went maybe if
it was it was going on behind the scenes
well I mean clearly a lot of like the
early episodes oh one more yeah the
early stuff is more fluffy so maybe as
they're working on the fluff episodes
behind the scenes but it did yeah it
doesn't feel like oh we're writing
ourselves in the corner oh we're really
desperate we have to know this feels
really well put together yeah you know
they still can have an episode where
they can either do more of a light
fluffy episode or even when they go into
more emotional ones like the because of
the way it's structured it doesn't have
to be exact it doesn't to be like well
that continuity ties it suffer
continuity and how they confuse it it's
like they can you don't exactly know I
mean what it means you're so many shows
out there like have the opposite
problems like you could tell their maker
they didn't have a plan or x-files is my
favorite example those first night like
it's come back and it's been fun to
watch so far but those first nine
seasons I'm like you could tell he had
Chris Carter no clue zero where
he was going with any of this and
he just kept like pulling random things
out and throwing against the wall
to see what stuck and what you get he's
not always bad I mean that can work I
say no no I'm not saying for a job I'm
saying in general if you make it up as
you go we're not saying don't do that
that's bad
that sure was made by the the fun
characters it for me wasn't made by the
mythological the myth arc yeah you know
the plot the the government conspiracy
plan I actually thought that was the
weakest part of the show so yeah but um
yeah and then there's other times where
you just see a show or something and
it's like where did this character come
from like this seems like a complete 180
oh well Israel's Dark Knight Rises like
Alfred yeah who was this guy in Dark
Knight like now I was like oh my god
oh no it's all planned out when they
have Ra's al Ghul in the first film and
they killed him off if Bane is going to
continue with storing the next don't
know the film after that brilliant burst
it's about the junior and escalation and
then we're going to drop that whole
thing and go back right back to the
first line we have a farm that's a great
example of like I feel like no one
probably blew his load on the Dark
Knight and like that was the story
really watched of then they're like what
we knew third we're gonna trilogy this
out but but I mean I did Dark Knight we
will pay you enough that you never have
to work again
neither were your children or your
children's children it's like Frank
Herbert who wrote the dude series like
he said after the got it burden they
like I really was done but they kept
offering me paycheck after paycheck it's
like who can refuse money like that well
no they're my Python they said that too
with meeting a life they said if you do
one more movie we can make it where you
never have to work another great example
would be Cora like that one I don't
think it was their fault I think they
had a plan for one season to the Nick
kept dicking them around and so you
could tell me didn't have any idea
initially where cousin like this was
meant to be a one season show that's
what you assholes were telling us you
were going to renew us and then all of a
sudden that's like when we got a second
season so the rewriting parts in the
first season in the second season then
the Third's it like you could tell that
it is just going in all sorts of
directions it's don't get show but yeah
and I like Legend of Korra a lot but
this doesn't feel that way
I actually it's refreshing to feel
something that feels like yeah they've
got a real grasp on these guys yeah
definitely really well done but very
nicely done episode and yeah looking
forward to more great ones like that so
let's get to that later Poe girl :